landing in a new city and with a new job
to do
seventeen years after he made his debut
for barcelona lionel messi has finally
switched clubs
these fans outside the park de pras and
at le bourget airport waited all weekend
for the news that came in on tuesday the
argentinian agreeing a deal with paris
saint-germain and flying to the french
capital in a move that may indicate the
final shifting of power in european club
football
the bigger picture is that
new money is taking over
for the big decisions that all money
will just moan and moan and moan but
that's meant that
they've been left behind
basically barcelona for a while for too
long i've been trying to behave as if
they were new money as if they had more
money than actually they did if psg
comply with financial for play
they've done the job the ones who
haven't been doing the job is barcelona
who have been punching all their weight
and now they have to realize that they
cannot afford a ferrari so they're going
to have to look into having to see it
instead
this is just the latest bit of good
business by psg
in this window they've signed barsa
captain messi sergio ramos the real
madrid captain georgie weinald and the
netherlands captain and the winner of
the euro 2020 best player award
gianluigi donnarumma all on free
transfers messi will cost psg in other
ways his contract is about 41 million a
year for two years with an option of a
third good timing for when france's
delayed financial restrictions come into
force
with the argentinian now 34 paris don't
have a lot of time to cash in
football is a magic sport and even if
you have the best players it doesn't
mean you are going to win of course with
neymar
probably with them if he stays and now
with messi this is for me the best
strikers the the the three best front of
the history of football but it doesn't
mean they are going to win champions
league
it's the end of an era in barcelona
where fans are questioning how they
recover from a series of setbacks in
recent years
in paris they hope this is the latest
stop on their journey to the top
players like liberian superstar george
weir were in the team when paris
saint-germain won the french league in
the mid-90s but they then went nearly
two decades without winning the title
until qatari money and superstar
signings like zlatan
ibrahimovic now by signing arguably the
greatest player in history lionel messi
they hope to bridge that gap and win the
best trophy of all the champions league
and perhaps become the best and most
glamorous team on the planet
paul reese al jazeera paris